yes thanks to Koh bid Harvard's offering
online classes for students but at the
same price as the old grift at 50 grand
does it matter
after all a Harvard education really
isn't for the education it's for the
name Harvard is the ultimate virtue
signal for the elites they're selling
authority same way the New York Times
does so wherever you go among the
corridors of pretension you find these
clowns always trying to act casual when
they drop Harvard into a conversation
it's then you see how it overpriced
overvalued education leaves you with
overbearing drips who wear bowties but
still can't tie them but this is where
kovat helps because online classes will
make college way better for parents for
it'll be easier to see how professors
who were indoctrinated a decade before
are indoctrinating now the parent can
see what garbage is being ladled into
their offsprings skulls right from their
very laptop you'll soon realize that
college is vocational training for
idiots on how to throw tantrums on tick
tock academia is exposed for what it is
a scam and so you see where your cash
really goes not to education but to
administrators who balloon costs from
kindergarten to grad school fact is our
education system doesn't make people
smarter it makes some people richer and
others poorer and judging by the nature
of today's leftist Dumber infantile and
obviously unstable tuitions are at an
all-time high but carry-out intelligence
is at an all-time low so I say go online
the best part no weird college roommates
unless you count mom and dad so Dana I
have a theory that I think you'll like
once we combine online courses with
actual talented performers college is
dead
meaning if academia mimicked peloton
which basically took the gym out of the
gym and brought it online and then hired
extremely charismatic talented
performers to exercise the gym becomes
irrelevant if they apply that model to
college and put it on YouTube who needs
Harvard
I totally agree education I think has
been forever changed because of
coronavirus I don't think that is being
too extreme either I mean looking at
place like Purdue University in the last
I believe seven years they've not raised
tuition at all their graduates do very
well they have connections to employers
that help pay for tuition for lower
income students and the education is
superb I remember when I was a kid Greg
I wanted guest jeans so badly and my mom
and dad were like no levi's will do just
fine for you and I was so upset because
I wanted that brand and the truth is
Levi's were excellent jeans and I think
that's what people are going to start to
find out that if Harvard part of the
thing of going to college is the
experience right it's not just going to
class it's that you get to meet people
you hang out you get to go to lectures
you get to go to parties get to all
stuff how in the world
Harvard could not have figured out how
to lower the tuition price for people in
this situation makes me think that
they're just they don't even want to
remember they try to get the PPP loans
as well so I think that education is
forever change and I do hope that some
new institutions are built out of this
what about somebody like Peter Thiel who
had that great program to offer people
some money didn't go to college but what
about something more structured and a
new institution that people could look
to because we're in a whole new world
why not we just we should just all just
go for it exactly you know Jesse Dana
brought up the the point about you know
people go to college because it's part
of it for the experience I believe and I
know you disagree that the college
experience is completely overrated but
I'm sure you feel differently well I
don't know what you did in college Greg
but I thought the college experience was
pretty helpful but everybody knows the
hardest part about Harvard is getting
into Harvard once you're into Harvard
it's like impossible to get below a B
they what do they say like half of life
is just showing up well same with
Harvard but now you don't even have to
show up so it's like the University of
Phoenix Cambridge campus so
what you need to do is somehow quantify
the Harvard experience and then lop that
cost off of the tuition and I don't see
why people aren't burning up the
trustees phones right now with that very
idea because if your Harvard you
probably don't want to open because of
litigation or because some of the
professors are 65 and over and they
don't want to sit in the classroom with
a bunch of young carrier so in that case
slap on a mask rack the window and
separate the desk six feet or do it
everybody loves hold classes outside in
the quad on the football field
I'm sure Yale is doing that but I think
Yale's changing their name so that's
another story one isn't part of this
right it's gonna be great for parents
because they might be able to see
exactly what's being taught right sure
I'm not sure I'd understand I mean you
know gosh you get into some of these
more theoretical classes it's tough I
went back and read my thesis a couple
years ago I didn't understand the word
but I mean to your point oh here's where
I come down Greg III gotta tell you you
know Harvard's a private institution
right if you get into Harvard and you
don't want to go don't enroll don't pay
the price you can make that call I just
don't think many people are going to
make that call on a very practical level
most people understand that it's not
just about the credential which is very
impressive a Harvard education but it's
also about associating with other very
smart people who are going somewhere in
life it's a very select group of people
and even if they aren't able to come
together initially for next year because
of the kovat virus situation that
doesn't mean they're not going to get
back together come 2021 late 20 21 20 22
and beyond the the thing that I of
course I'm reacting to today is the
president saying everybody's got to have
schools open in the fall and of course
it's not only the professor's it's the
teachers that the elementary in high
schools who say they worry for
themselves
it's parents who worry about what
happens if you know you can't hard to
have social distancing on a school bus
they're real issues that we have to deal
with and instead of making it political
I think we should really talk about how
can we get schools to work this fall I
don't think anybody made it political
when you said you want to open the
schools that's actually making a
statement poletik politicizing is saying
but you didn't think about the help the
help problems everybody's everybody
knows the health problems by the way I
think parents will be kind of relieved
that their kids are going back to school
if I was a parent I'd want him out of
the house Emily last word to you yeah
but you know you don't want to you don't
want to get sick you know right I'm all
doing I never thought of it I pray thank
you this doesn't surprise me at all you
guys remember when the university of
california hiked tuition and then it was
you know it became known that 85% of
that hike was because of pensions like
sure this is that association with the
exclusivity but it's also just bad math
Harvard has the largest endowment in the
country right Lester it was almost 41
billion and yet they pay out 70% of
their student body get some financial
aid in some way so it makes all the
sense to me that they want at lower cost
even if there's no operating overhead
anymore of course because they have to
pay all the bills all of those things
that the pensions the professor worship
the professorships everything all of
their extended obligations and debts
those are not going anywhere it's just
bad math